hey I'm impressed man who table playing
there is no game that's all I know about
this game that there is no game and I
can select bronze French or English I'll
go with English thank you I feel like I
have more British people watching or
American may bike also it is made by
someone probably not made by okay that
just wasn't a game there for a second
there is no gay well I hope you enjoyed
this video it's a little user all right
I have that you Oh God actually there's
no game well that's not a surprise hope
you're not too much disappointed I mean
not really you can still watch TV go
outside go outside oh god now is coming
for a refund
no no refund that Ken's free Jesus is
not again
it has nothing to do it again it's just
a massive package of boredom
alright then leave a like if you enjoyed
it subscribe to become a nothing to do
with here okay then
well then quit leave me alone maybe I
will
Thank You me you're welcome alright bye
goodbye and inside spending great oh end
please do not touch the title it's not
quite dry yet you know what I don't care
I live life from the edge oh the ladder
Oh huh I'm a poke this letter R s [ __ ]
yeah you've just ruined the title I'm
sorry
put good at the back okay I can't come
on yeah maybe I'll put it over here
coming in a mine I will fix it next time
someone we love the game and final game
then on game of course no game here ok
whatever you say man it's broken
Oh what is that something's coming out
every time I drop it what are you where
are you oh [ __ ] - Sam are you going to
kill me I'm gonna choke got you [ __ ] no
I think we're good now you're nothing
you
yeah class Superman for that one just in
case what
a few Krypton I know Superman does not
exist but house we're gonna get no we're
not that's ready game no we're not so
weird you're still there Oh mister oh my
life what is this mess there game I hope
you will clean the place before living I
went oh my god am i unscrewing the
screws of the game just what do you
think you're doing user I'm sorry
no come come
are you talking about your mom - no I
don't care okay
all right Linda looks like I can't fail
I need it - it's calling me what Sam how
do I can't move it anymore
every gap will be harder than that
without the bowl it will be hard over
that ball but it says I have two more
then what the [ __ ] anyway okay no more
Bowl nowhere no way there's no balls
what about this please I will never
leave oh [ __ ] Oh No they're here
oh my god nothing everywhere pictures
every [ __ ] told you to stop I'm sorry
wait to get rid of them
that's heavy you're not a game what
developer would implement well sell
above aggression I see three possible
things or just bombed hero girls or ton
of zombies and grow the force yeah goat
I know I gotta try to find one of these
three things
as an arrow here what are you joking
with me come on take the litter is gonna
help us okay
did you say goat do someone say go and
go go away I would exhume bees okay
subtracted no way okay we gotta go hoots
oh my god oh yeah I got this you just
look you must plan the key let's [ __ ]
steak I don't know where the kids go jab
me where the key is right now Derby what
the [ __ ]
that flying squirrel took it you must
get it back
find another or something to go off
something you can climb that ladder
minds me of my childhood I used to climb
the huge tree in the garden good luck my
kite yes I heard the childhood any tree
wide if I put the letters as a ladder uh
okay okay wait we got we got a trophy
come here trophy all right we'll grab
the water hand cards drink the water
birth stir don't speak English and
you're just digging everywhere sympathy
shut up
three the glitches are coming girl by
child
I know how to sell bass big cry my child
grows - Alexis beautiful mammal you're
on my child girl damn you got em with
Samuel this is so [ __ ] weird I don't
know what I'm doing I thought I wasn't
playing a game and then and I'm playing
a game and glitches and all right we can
go up now thanks to Kate stupid demon
you can have this trophy
never mind what was that I got a little
piece up do you want this alright I'll
just drop it keep dropping it yeah well
what if I do this yeah genius here you
go sir
now I should I'm that case I do granny
no guess I good to turn from that
glitchy program into a commercial hit
okay as we halt sector wall st. big us a
twirl across there you go guys save the
world
yeah suck my life
just wanna go to save my life and then
it just just do it god damn it what the
[ __ ] oh yes I'm wanted
I'll catch him it I was wrong it was a
bad idea it was a bad idea everything
disappeared except me
well fine I'm so sorry I'm tight put you
in danger it's all my fault
we love each other it's okay will you
forgive me obviously yes yes what news
yes we can be friends I mean yeah no
that's not a good idea okay mines bored
quickly together why because as I said
there's the game there is no game
now you can quit and play a game I don't
believe it I think this is not a trinket
you didn't have good
and okay I'm hoping the game engineer
but that was a lot of fun really cool
game your brothers can check it out
yourself a live link to it in the
description hope you had fun playing the
note not playing this game with me and
thank you for watching I'll see in the
next one say awesome press